Today is the end of week one.
Day five is down.
This class is very front-loaded.
So I think the students
feel it, and I definitely
felt it yesterday.
Yesterday was probably the
peak of just the exhaustion
of the class, and getting
used to doing that in addition
to my day job.
I was frustrated because I
wanted the students to see what
I was seeing, and they weren't.
And I felt like it was
because of an inability
to clearly articulate what I
was trying to get them to see.
Today was so different.
We started class
with having them
pitch the idea, or the
point, of their videos.
And there's this nuance
between an idea of the video,
the point of the video,
and what a video does.
And it wasn't until
this morning that I
was-- I finally was able to
articulate in my head what
was going on with the students,
which was the inability
to distinguish a
point from an action.
So a lot of them were describing
what their videos did,
and using that description
as the point of the video.
And I feel like we finally
all make a breakthrough.
Today was when it sort of
became real to everyone
because they got to
take their cameras
and actually go shoot stuff.
And it was just incredibly
gratifying to overhear
them shoot, and hear them offer
each other the same pieces
of advice I would.
And See them take
creative risks,
and experiment
with the equipment.
And to also see they really
are a good class group.
They're just a really
good group of students
I front-loaded the class, and
I'm realizing that it really
was a lot work for them.
I wanted to equip the
students as best I could
with the skills
they needed to have
so that the rest of the month
could be more about them trying
stuff on their own.
And I don't know how I
would re-structure that.
It's something that I
have to think about a lot.
I thought about that a
lot coming into the class,
but it was still a lot of
work for them this week.
In short, today was excellent.
I saw smiles on people's
faces, and witnessed
them integrating things that
we had taught them this week.